thinking in words is a lower form of
thinking and communication pack thought
form is the most condensed form of the
direct knowing of that thing it gets
transmitted in an instant to be able to
receive the pack thought forms is
essential to be able to have direct
communication with non-physical beings
and non-physical realities because
that's how they communicate and we're
surrounded by them all the time we're
like fish in a in a sea that we're
surrounded by water but we don't know
water exists we're embedded in the
spiritual world but if we don't have the
eyes to see it we haven't developed the
internal organs of perception we'll
never know that we're surrounded by
Spiritual Beings all the time that are
conveying information to us and those
Spiritual Beings are of varying levels
of reliability just like you have to
have some discernment with the company
you keep on the physical plane you have
to have discernment of The Company You
Keep in the non-physical world